he's not getting nearly enough coverage
even though the announcement came
yesterday classic lame stream media
doesn't want to cover the real
candidates that person of course would
be Joe Exotic yes the Tiger King who is
currently in prison for uh hiring a
Hitman to kill his Nemesis Carol Baskin
Joe Exotic is declared that he is
running for president in his
announcement he said put aside that I am
gay that I am in prison for now that I
used drugs in the past that I had more
than one boyfriend at once and that
Carol hates my guts this all has not a
thing to do with me being able to be
your voice the best thing you have going
for supporting me is that I am used to
fighting my whole life just to get by I
am broke they have taken everything I
ever worked for away and it's time we
take this country back